i saw a woman a couple months back
professional soccer player right she
goes on to espn on one of these sports
channels and she starts bitching
going like i don't understand how come
female athletes don't make as much as
male professional athletes
right and all of these men had to sit
there and act like they didn't know what
the answer was
they had to sit there like dumbfounded
like
[Music]
why is that
that is a conundrum i have i have no
idea
literally i'm sitting at home screaming
at the tv because you don't sell any
[ __ ] tickets
nobody is going to women's soccer games
you're playing in a 20 000 scene arena
1500 people show up that's not a good
night
the promoter lost his [ __ ] ass on
that kick
i don't know
i find a lot of that a lot of that
racial stuff like fascinating you know
like the different rules of like how who
gets in trouble who doesn't like i've
noticed black people have the genius to
put the curse word after they say the
race of the person
where white dudes we always put it in
front and if we would just make that
little adjustment we could save so many
careers
so many jobs
could be saved in the white community if
we would just put it after
you never notice that in conversation
here black everyone like man i was
standing in this asian [ __ ] came
in he starts talking about her you don't
even hear it
you're just sitting there what did this
asian [ __ ] do
i would love to hear the rest of this
story right
dude i would tell the exact same story
right i'm standing there right this
[ __ ] asian comes in right everybody's
all like whoa whoa hey easy easy jesus
dude
what year is it you know
it's like dude i just said what he said
i just preempted the [ __ ] that's all i
did he suggested he's hooking up with
people's mothers i'm not even doing that
it's just a quick i got it out of the
way i got it out of the way
just how i talk the [ __ ] guy came in
this is [ __ ] asian
yeah there's nothing stopping you
other than the fact that you guys are
just into destroying each other
no now it's gonna get quiet
i see all that sneaky [ __ ] you do
ladies if you could just support the
wnba the way you support a fat chick
that's proud of her body and is no
longer a threat to you
you know
that league would be doing better
numbers in the nba
oh my god that's one of the saddest
things i've ever seen oh my god you're a
goddess you're gorgeous you look great
that bikini i would kill myself if i
look like that keep eating keep eating
lose a toe you fat [ __ ] it's just
that's how it's become [ __ ] us
everything's so goddamn every [ __ ]
joke you tell what did you mean about
that
i didn't go to the gym today are you
calling me fat i feel [ __ ] triggered
gotta [ __ ] apologize to everybody
this is how screwed up my country is
right now do you you know you know brian
cranston right
that dude did a movie he played a
quadriplegic
and people gave him [ __ ]
being like why is there an able-bodied
person
playing a quadriplegic
it's like it's because it's called
acting
you dumb [ __ ]
see if he was a quadriplegic playing a
quadriplegic that's not acting
that's just [ __ ] laying there saying
[ __ ] that someone else wrote
so tell us what what did you do to
prepare for the role well i dove head
headfirst into the shallow end of a pool
when i was 23.
i feel like i've been preparing for this
role for my whole life
right what is up next for you oh well
they're gonna do a reboot of top gun uh
i'm gonna fly my prog uh the co-pilot's
gonna be transgendered
so everybody will be happy
she won't die her discarded dick will
block her head from the
canopy there'll be a gender neutral
bathroom on the plane
how [ __ ] dumb is that that's
literally like watching a movie why
didn't you have a murderer play a
murderer and how come the guy he shot i
saw him in another movie
i mean what the [ __ ] is going on
no i don't know what it is
i don't know what it is i don't know
what the [ __ ] is going on
but i think white women started it
ah
it's the worst
the [ __ ] worst that's all they do is
[ __ ] mother and complain i had no idea
how difficult it was
to be a white woman in the united states
of america
evidently it's really difficult
yeah they're always bitching do you have
any idea what it's like to be me
well i imagine it would be slightly less
awesome than my life
what happened to you today sweetheart
huh did they not chill your rose
you know
was the trolley not running down at the
mall what happened
no it's unreal i'm really [ __ ]
annoyed how white women have the [ __ ]
balls to throw my white privilege in my
face you know
sorry to separate themselves from these
white males with their white male
privileges like [ __ ] you're sitting in
a jacuzzi with me
put your [ __ ] whining
look
there's a little caveat here so you
don't think i'm a complete [ __ ] right
out of the gate all right if you're
[ __ ] if you live in some honey boo
boo lifestyle on the appalachian trail
you know your uncle just banged you in
the dirt all right
every white person likes to lie to
themselves that they are alive you know
150 years ago that they would have been
working on the underground railroad
trying to help slaves escape right i
would be one of the good white people
i would have taken time out of my day
risk my life and the reality is is you'd
be doing back then exactly what you're
doing today nothing
not a [ __ ] thing maybe a little
hashtag black lives matter oh my god my
heart breaks on my l-shaped couch
my favorite thing about the black lives
matter marches was the the store windows
that would have the plywood over the
windows and then it would say black
lives matter on top of the plywood i
just love the duality of that message
you know it's like black lives matter
we're all the same we're all one don't
burn down my store you [ __ ] animals
everybody
is welcome in this store anyone can come
in one at a time follow him this is how
they argue as far as i can tell all
right if they're right they argue the
point and they stay on point and make
sure you stay on point until you're down
on your knees apologizing begging for
forgiveness all right no problem with
that totally respect it but here's the
thing if they're wrong they go rogue
they go off-road they start thinking of
[ __ ] you're sensitive about maybe you
don't get along with your dad and in
their head they just start concocting
this evil statement
totally designed this desperate hail
mary attempt
to make you so [ __ ] mad you just call
him a [ __ ]
that's what it is
and [ __ ] trumps all the [ __ ] they
did to start the argument now it's not
about that one there's no reason to call
me a [ __ ] and then that's it you're in
this room now right
my girl knows my big thing is my big
fear in life is to be that dude who
grows old you know grows old alone has
like that basement apartment
just screaming up at the younger couple
turn it down
that isn't music
so i noticed that anytime she was losing
a fight i don't know what she just feels
but that's why you're just going to grow
old and be alone then
i lose my [ __ ]
the next thing you know i'm in the
kitchen washing dishes for the ninth
[ __ ] time in a row this is what the
argument was about i was so right what
happened
so if you learn anything from my
ignorance tonight
just know this next time you're in a
battle with your beautiful woman your
wife girlfriend whatever and they start
out of nowhere okay you're winning and
they just start saying that crazy [ __ ]
out of nowhere just know in that moment
you've won the fight okay
all right don't get mad bob and weave
slip all of that [ __ ] maybe because you
got a little dick just let that slide
stay in the pocket of the argument
okay it's over the argument is over you
one just take a knee and run out the
clock all right
yes lean on the ropes let them punch
themselves out
and then in the end you throw their
psychology right back at them well maybe
we should discuss it later when you calm
down
and they won't hook up with you for a
couple of days who cares
who cares you rub one out
rub one out like a man it's a champagne
a victory
no means no that's another one no means
now it's like no it doesn't
all right
look look no means no no that means no
all right but no stop it what are you
doing
oh my god
you're being so bad stupid
no
yeah that's not a [ __ ] note
that means i want to do it but i'm
afraid you're going to judge me so i'm
just going to make it look like it was
your idea so you don't figure out that
i've already performed this act with 40
other [ __ ] people right
but then
then you go to court and you get a bad
read and there's some guy reading it uh
your honor she said no stop it what are
you doing you're being so bad
yeah and you just sent me like she
didn't [ __ ] say it like that she
didn't say it like that